now when you have a look back right uh i
actually think this is um
yeah it's it's three marks worth of work
but most of the like if you compare this
to three marks elsewhere in the paper
like say with a you know an integration
recurrence relation are the easy
examples for me to go to like you've got
pages of algebra here this is quite
succinct but the reason why these three
marks associated with this is how much
thinking you have to do
going from like coming up with these
equations that's like a whole mark on
its own this solving simultaneously and
then equating is kind of one piece um
and there's a fair bit of work there
conceptually to do that and then the
substitution is actually fairly
straightforward especially because this
result is already known
and by the way that is o
t as required because um this is the
particular value of lambda that gets me
onto t
all right so well done uh you can see
we've just got a few minutes left so
just before i finish out part four of
this multi-part question i did promise
another method right so we use the
vector equations of lines to do this but
you can
use euclidean geometry and similar
triangles to do this right i won't walk
you through every single step of this
because it's quite long and arduous but
i will get um the key parts of the logic
for you okay
what we're using here is the fact that
you've got because you've got
parallelograms right um you've got this
similar triangle let's um let's shade it
here for you so if i do this that's
roughly right will it snap into place no
it won't because my triangle was too
messy let's try again there we go oh no
it thinks it's like ah forget it i'm
just going to color it myself
you want something done do it yourself
uh it'll be messy but there you go i'm
comparing this triangle here
to this triangle here right can you see
they are going to have to be um
uh similar to each other i mean you
could if you were a bit sneaky and i
think it's sort of valid in extension 2
context you could almost say they're
similar by inspection but if i had time
i'd definitely come back and fill in
this proof as i have done here you can
see you've got these
vertically opposite angles and then you
pick an appropriate pair i picked this
pair here
of alternate angles because you've got
these parallel lines from the
parallelogram right
so uh once you've got that once you've
stated that you can you know you only
have i'm missing a line of working here
i wonder how i no no i think there was a
line here that was missing from a page
break sorry about that um i've got one
angle here one angle here that's enough
for equiangular and then this gets the
proportions going but i just want to
point out this is there's some like if
you if you did this similar triangle as
proof or use something like this in the
future you have to be quite careful
right this kind of notation here when
you make a statement about corresponding
sides and similar triangles you're
making a comment about
lengths right that's the magnitude of
vectors not vectors themselves so you
can see that's why i employ this sort of
absolute value notation to indicate i'm
talking about magnitude only it's a
pretty pretty classic thing that
students miss out when they're doing
proofs like this and that's what they're
searching for right
using the accurate notation in a three
mark proof so you can see i've got the
magnitude of p itself will cancel that
just leaves you with the half it's on
the denominator that's why you get two
and then i i continue going you can
access the recording of this later to
follow my exact lines of logic through
my diagram
and then
i pull a similar move here that i pulled
earlier in the day
you can't just say that you know because
you've got this
uh length relationship this magnitude
relationship you can't just go straight
from here
to here without justifying right because
if ot and os were like completely off in
different directions like they were
perpendicular or they were like a skew
or something like that then you can't
say that this vector is just two-thirds
of another vector um because this is
implying their directions are identical
right but and they only differ in length
in magnitude so you must make this
comment here it's crucial um because
remember this is a proof question so
please make note of that if you're doing
um you just can't simply make this move
without justification
and then from there the algebra is very
similar to what we did before okay
all right now um just because of the
sake of time i'm going to cheat a little
bit and show you rather than write it
live for you i'm going to show you the
solution that i wrote previously for
part 4.
let's remember what the question is we
need to show that using parts 2 and 3
that t divides pr in this particular
ratio two to one okay so how do we do
that
what i've done is i've employed this
simple logic that i had before and just
to put t somewhere um dividing this
interval in some unknown ratio right and
what i want to prove is that i know what
that ratio is equal to so i've got my
diagram
i can use part two i just quote part two
um with regard to ot except instead of
um you know the
the m's and n's that were for part one
and two which were kind of unknown i
have a known m and n which is what i'm
working toward right so therefore this
um this m and n appear here from part
two it's unknown at that point but once
you use the path three result which
that's what i just proved in the
previous line you can just simply make a
comparison here right can you see that
this part uh out the front of p is gonna
be the same as this coefficient and uh
the same deal with this coefficient and
the two two-thirds right so when i
compare those you get you can see what
fits into m and n you get given a bit of
a leg up because they tell you it's in
the ratio two to one anyway so even if
it wasn't obvious you could just kind of
try out the numbers
and that tells you that m which is the
right hand part is one and n which is
the left-hand part is two and that's
that's it there's my proof for one mark
so i apologize i went slightly over time
i just really wanted to give you that
time in the breakout rooms i hope you
found it worthwhile
um this is a really great question
because you can see how much knowledge
it pulls in from different places and
that it wasn't i don't think there's
anything that's too rabbit out of a hat
if you think carefully about how
how all the vectors fit together and
what the diagram looks like and there it
is and how it relates to like the part
one and two diagram relates to the part
three and four diagram which in the
breakouts i know many of you mentioned